if you thought there was nothing else
that could be said about the josh rosen
kyler murray kyler's in josh is out
situation in arizona there is more to be
said and josh rosen recently said it in
an appearance on the rich eisens show he
explained that he still hasn't heard
from the guy who drafted him a year ago
and who drafted kyle murray this year
here's josh rosen on gm steve kahn
yeah i mean the only thing that like
truly did kind of
frustrate me through this whole process
that like i still haven't heard from
my old gm like
i didn't talk to him for months before
still haven't talked to him much after
but
that was kind of frustrating but for the
most part it's
i'm just ready to put that whole chapter
behind me
that's the first hint of any frustration
on the part of josh rosen who handled
the situation very very well and the
fact that he was left dangling by steve
kime for months before calamari was
picked and still hasn't heard from him
after that look
we may be getting a little bit of of a
window into the dysfunction that is the
arizona cardinals chris because i'm not
saying that steve kahn failed to contact
josh rosen maliciously maybe he just
felt awkward about it maybe he didn't
know what he was gonna say maybe he felt
guilty but whatever if you get it right
and and the world can be divided into
two general groups of people those who
get it and those who don't get it if you
get it you find a way to get in touch
with josh rosen either before you draft
kyler murray right after you pick kyle
murray right before you trade josh rosen
or after you trade him and rosen said
he's heard from cliff kingsbury multiple
times kingsbury never coached the guy
right time drafted him i i this one the
more i talk about it the more upset i
get because i i thought steve kind was a
certain way but when i hear that maybe i
maybe i've been wrong for the last six
years about steve khan i i mean i
understand what you're saying i get i
get steve kind maybe not talking to josh
rosen prior to the draft right just
doesn't want to tip his hand doesn't
want anything out there you know wants
to keep that first pick close to the
vest and not let anybody know what's
going on okay i get that that's fine but
yeah to me it's like inexplicable that
you don't call a guy who you drafted
with the number 10 pick the previous
year when you draft the number one
quarterback and you're going okay well
obviously this guy's gonna be you know
out the door or hey you know this is
what's going on with this situation uh
it's like business ethics okay i mean
that's that's one thing it's you know
kind of the breaking of the man code
it's an unwritten role rule of the nfl i
mean come on call a guy hey josh you
know sorry it didn't work out here in
arizona we didn't expect to love kyla
murray the way we did we did but we
really appreciate everything you did for
us good luck with the next chapter of
your life i mean is it that difficult to
me uh that is what proper leadership is
that's what you should do as a gm of a
football team
and to a guy who you put in a very tough
position for a few months really and
handled it other than unfollowing the
cardinals the night of the draft okay on
twitter or whatever i mean josh rosen
was pretty much perfect in the handling
of all this number one talk kyler murray
conversation
yeah especially when you consider he's a
kid in his early twenties right and he
was led to believe he's the guy in
arizona and now all of a sudden not only
is he not the guy he had to spend three
months feeling that oh they really don't
want me right now i'm on my way out and
nobody's being straight with me here
because they don't think they can trust
me with the information because they
think i'll tell somebody and then i will
ruin their little party on that thursday
night when they get to tell the world
they're taking kyler murray as if it was
a surprise at that point so i think
rosen handled himself incredibly well
i'm just really disappointed i'm sad to
hear this about steve khan because that
tells me that that i've read him wrong
because i would think that he i'd love
to know
and steve you you need to address this
you can't just you can't just
no comment there has to be uh either you
know he didn't
actually not call him or or there's a
reason for why he didn't do it but it
just feels like it cries out for
something from steve
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports